sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to another episode
of the lay heil pen show as always this episode
and this podcast is powered by icon plus capital
the vc firm so go check them out and it is also
sponsored by block fi so block fight offers some
really amazing interest rates if you're interested
i've left a link in the description and in
the comment section so i think you can get
around nine percent of your stable coins right
now which is pretty cool so joining me today i
have a very special guest we're talking all about
the american dream we're talking about privilege
we're talking about living in the most privileged
era and of course we're talking about bitcoin and
modern day society it is charles payne
the host of making money on fox business
charles welcome to the leia hill plan
show it's great to see you how you doing
i'm i'm great it's good to be on your show
yeah i'm super excited to get into this
um you're a really interesting character um you
have this interesting back story your upbringing
the air force working on wall street so i want to
get into all of this um and i really want to start
at the beginning basically um so i've watched
several podcasts of yours and you mentioned that
when you were much younger you moved to harlem and
in your words you grew up dirt poor um and you had
to hustle a lot with various different jobs from
the age of 12. so i'd love to understand where
that drive came from to start hustling because
for a lot of people that kind of set up in life is
just a terrible setup um and you know it's not a
great foundation so where did that drive come from
i i think part of it was that i was the
oldest so there were three boys and my mom
and uh you know and so you know we we had a
beautiful life we grew up around the world
uh living on a us army bases you know
i lived in germany i lived in japan
texas three times pittsburgh alabama north
carolina virginia so we lived all over the
world and i really never even thought about
money or any of that stuff i had chores but
you know not a lot of responsibility per se but
then we found ourselves in a sort of destitute
situation where all four of us are living inside
of a room uh so i just i just i had no i really
felt like i hadn't felt like i had no choice
uh so you know i just started to hustle and
you know i would clean car windows you know get a
buy a pack of tall paper towels some windex clean
windshields at stop lights and red red lights
and i would shovel snow and i kind of got lucky
i got a job in a bodega uh even though that
was rough like you know i i don't think people
now particularly people go to new york and go to
harlem when they go to nice restaurants understand
in the 1970s it was it was bombed out parts of it
looked like aleppo uh you know during the syrian
war it really was that bombed out uh junkies winos
uh crime it was it was rough and even working in a
bodega was pretty rough uh you know they tested
me all the time because i was different uh you
know so lots of fights a lot of intimidation but i
had no choice i i really felt like i had no choice
i think it's so interesting that you said
you had no choice because i feel we live in
a society um whereby people are always sort of
talking about um you know privilege and that's
one of the best ways to get ahead in life
but there's something about having no choice
which sort of pushes you it's like it's like
a it's like a rocket right it pushes you to
do better it really is it's um you know
and you know it's it's so amazing because
i mean obviously not everybody did what i did
right so uh you know that one intangible i'm
not 100 sure where it might have come from
i did i will say you know for my father who
wasn't necessarily i wasn't necessarily close
to but watching him in the military and the way
he took care of responsibilities you know
at night i would watch him shine his boots
and polish his belt buckle until he had this
the most amazing shine and he'd get dressed in
the morning have his gig line straight put
his cologne on so i did absorb some of that
i had a grandparents on the farm in alabama and
uh you know it's you know their story is even more
to me even more amazing in the sense that for
a black family to have a farm in the south
uh you know in the 50s and 60s and 70s it's really
just a mind-boggling thing and you know again they
went about they took care of business right they
didn't have indoor plumbing they didn't have
electricity uh you know until like the late 70s
but they raised a whole lot of kids and grandkids
and they were self-sufficient they didn't need
they needed to take they didn't need to ask
anybody for anything right so they grew crops they
had a few animals it was tough work so i think all
of those things contributed to me knowing that
i uh at least thinking i had to step up so i did
you had clearly really strong um you know father
figure parental sort of guidance i guess in that
sense so you know money aside because people
always look at money as that privilege or
skin color or you know gender or whatever it is to
what extent would you say having um a good example
would be you know that one of the most
privileged things that you could have
oh i think it's far and above the most important
thing and to be quite frank with you my mom was
far and away the most important symbol in my life
the most important person in my life uh and so um
it makes all the difference in the world you know
that's why i'm i'm really big on family family
structure and you know we live in a modern era so
it's not that hey you know what people are gonna
get married and be be together for 40 years and
for 50 years and you know but responsibility so
you may move on marriages may break up people
may never get married but the responsibility of
taking care of children and giving them hope and
you know teaching them responsibility that's still
very critical and i think that's where we have
fallen off in terms of the society so uh there's
nothing in my mind more important to that because
you're right it supersedes everything and in what
way do you think we've fallen off as a society uh
you know just accountability uh just the notion of
lack of responsibility individual responsibility
individual accountability uh and and just you know
for instance i i find hiring young people a lot
of young people they don't take criticism well
uh you know or or yeah i just i just feel
like there's a certain kind of humbleness
that you come up through life with and and and
you know you give respect you get respect um but
there just seems to be so many excuses that are
laid out and it's so hard to have to be honest
with someone and say hey no this is your problem
but you can fix it but it is a problem so we skirt
around the issues and in our world uh you know
people don't commit crimes guns commit crimes
right and our world uh you know it's not
what people do it's it's sort of the outcome
that becomes villainized and and
that never gets to the real issue
so i think we've got some serious issues there
uh and uh you know a lot of it too is it's just
a country and a world really that has lost has
lost i don't i don't say respect but sort of
we've lost faith in a lot of things and you know
and i don't go to church every sunday but i'm
a strong believer in god uh and uh you know
but we've lost faith in almost every sort of
institution that people used to look up to as
well so you had the family structure but you
also had the church you believed in your local
government maybe uh you know you believed in
certain things um and these days you know
you look at all these different surveys and
uh our our faith in in these agencies are have
collapsed you know the only thing i've seen that
has gone up in the last 40 years is maybe the
police department uh but outside of that whether
it's the supreme court congress the media uh you
know every single one of them we've lost complete
faith in and again some of that is warranted some
of it also is an excuse because we started laying
off what we should be achieving on our own to
other people you know oh that guy was bad i i've
had people tell me oh i didn't do well when reagan
was president well that ain't reagan's fault
i mean yeah you know there's a certain amount of
president can do to set up the backdrop for you
to succeed but ultimately no matter if it's
the worst president in the world or the best
uh you know if you grow poor if you grow up rich
you still have to be the author of your life
and that means accepting where you've made big
mistakes and if you do that the right way you'll
be able to correct them yeah it's this constant
sort of um celebration of victim mentality i think
that's the problem and you know the whole idea
of you know good times create weak men well it's
not just men but it's people and i always say
that western society sort of peaked in the 90s
which allowed this new generation millennials
unfortunately and one of them to just become one
of the one of the weakest sort of generations
that we've seen um and so i think you know i
think people this is also why i love crypto
i think you know people need to be empowered
to um realize that there is opportunity out
there because i think people often think that the
american dream is sort of dead um but in in your
instance you know because you did have a difficult
upbringing um like you mentioned so at what point
did you have the realization that you know the
world isn't against you there is money to be made
out there it is a bit of a game you know with the
stock market you need to know how to play it and
so at what point did you have that realization
because also because also when you when you
do grow up um you know not with a dirt poor
as you said you often think that that is normal
you know that is all there is out there right
well it is normal right i mean for where
you live everyone is in the same boat
i will say the one uh serious advantage
that i had over over my neighbors and and
the people i went to school with when i got to
harlem is i had already lived around the world
and i had i had friends in japan and they were
teaching me japanese and uh you know i lived in
germany and i had all these different i've gone
to all these different schools and you know i got
to be honest i didn't equate being great or smart
or hard-working or an intelligent with being white
and you know i was really shocked you know when i
first moved to harlem and i don't know the first
time someone said man you trying to act like a
white boy and i'm like what do you mean like you
know i want one time you know like getting
straight a's you were trying to be you were
being white speaking proper english you were being
white so automatically if you tell yourself that
that speaking proper english is not black you've
set yourself back you've automatically have put
yourself in such a compromised position that
there's no way in the world you're going to
be able to maximize your potential and then you
compound that with the fact that there is racism
out there so all it takes is if you even give
it a shot and you get a job somewhere someone
treats you like it really doesn't treat you well
you're gonna say i told you i knew they were like
this i can't make it we can't make it and so
it's a difficult premise when you've already
sort of established that so i was very very lucky
you know when i was in third grade third or fourth
grade i had a math teacher and uh she her and
her husband got their orders right and they were
leaving so it was her last day and once she was
the teacher she's my two kids get a better time
and she would ask a math question whoever
got it right the other kid had to sit down
i used to run through the entire class i just
crushed them all i would just crush them all
and it was like 95 white kids and so when she got
her order she said you know everyone i'm leaving
and she asked me if i could stand up and
she said i was the best student she ever had
so in that respect i was lucky like you know i
can't say i i really do know that that gave me
an advantage over someone who grew up from day one
thinking that speaking proper english was being
white or excelling academically was being white so
i did have that advantage and and that's the thing
i wish and i hope never has to be a disadvantage
that you know as time goes on people don't have
to put themselves down or look at themselves in a
certain way uh and so it's it so there wasn't any
particular epiphany per se i did have that going
for me and it worked out like when i was going job
interviews i went on a job interview and i was 17
at mcdonald's i finished high school but i had six
months before i was going into the air force i had
they had delayed not five months it was the lake
and i'd said the last thing you wanted
in my neighborhood was to sit around
if you were just sitting around you're
gonna get in trouble one way or the other
so i went to i saw it out in the paper they used
to have these things called newspapers by the way
i'm gonna i'm gonna send you one one day so
i i saw an ad in newspaper and i went down
it was two blocks three blocks away from it it
was ironic because it was trump's first major
building in new york there there's the grand hyatt
hotel and 300 people showed up for three jobs
and so they did all these rounds of interviews
right they did a round and then they would get
rid of half the people and do another round so
they did the first round of interviews and then
they got ready for the second round and when i
went over you know they called me up and went over
and the guy says don't worry about it you're hired
already so i just sat there and i had to wait like
two hours two or three hours for them to finish
the entire process so in that regard i don't
know what i said to them what they saw in me but
there was definitely something that made me stand
out because i got the job without having to go
through all those rounds after one round right so
and i think that was sort of the idea that you
know i i did spend time in different places and
i and i different i definitely knew different
kind of people and i don't know if that just
came through or whatever but you know it was
it was well i got the job so that was good
you said something really fascinating which was
um you know stop acting like a white person so
you know you'd be speaking well or doing well
whatever it is and the response you would get
would be stop speaking like a white person and i
hear that a lot um i hear that you know obviously
i'm based in the uk but you know it's the same
conversation i hear and it sort of reminds me
of the whole crabs in a bucket sort of idea i'd
like to understand you know why you think that
happens because you know you're sort of damned
if you're doing dams if you don't right because
like you said that compounded with actual racism
that exists you're sort of damned either way right
you know and i've heard the term crabs in a bucket
the only thing i would say the crabs are all
trying to save themselves they don't know they're
pulling the other one down with human beings we
know we're pulling each other down um so uh you
know listen it was really even rougher than that
because i mean i took some serious ass weapons
right for for sounding like a white person really
oh let me tell you one of the first things i that
that that the difference between growing up on
army bases and living in harlem in the 1970s were
the for the fights the physicality you know i had
like two fights maybe three i know for a fact i
had two when i lived on these army bases one man
me and my friend we had a fight we were playing
football and you know i this fight lasted i think
two minutes one minute and then we finished
and then we were friends again you know and
we played finished the football game and we had a
soda pop the other one was uh this with this kid
and we rolled around on the ground for a while but
again you know it was no big deal i didn't realize
like you know we moved to new york it was like yo
you fight to the death you start fighting you and
you i'm my longest fight i mean this kid fought
for 40 minutes one time we covered three blocks
i don't even know how the hell we got there like
you know you just fight and all of a sudden no
one would break it up and it's just like you know
so so it was dangerous to sound like a white kid
it was like oh god uh you know do i really want
to get an a right now i went home from school
and i damn sure had to run home from school
so you know it was um you know the the
the thing is though and and this is why i'm
praying and hoping that one day we can change that
so there's not that internal pressure you know
and you know it's it's it's easier said than done
you know it's it's a it's a societal thing um
you know um every now and then you see a nice
disney movie i remember keela and the bee and
this girl was in a crime infested neighborhood
but she was great at spelling and nobody bothered
it right you know just it's just you know it's a
prayerful thing that we get to that point um um
we're not there yet even as a society i don't
think you know race excluding race we don't
appreciate uh intellect the way the rest of
the world does and i'll give you a great example
there's a guy named jim clark i'm not sure if
you ever heard of him i think he may have the
distinction of being the only person who created
three separate multi-billion dollar corporations i
think his first one was a company called netscape
so jim clark this guy wrote a book about him um
michael lewis michael lewis is like one of the
most famous authors when it comes to you know
wall street books and so he wrote a book about
jim clark called the new new thing and in the
book there's a part in there and i got to buy
the book i was looking at my library the other
day and i couldn't find it but i remember there
being a partner where there was a guy who
was always with jim clark a guy from india
so lewis said you know can i talk to
him so he interviewed this guy and uh
during the course of the interview the guy he
came from a small village in india and he's
like you know talking about his background and
his sister was the prettiest girl in the village
and one day he came home from school and she
was getting all gussied up right it's like oh
what's going on she's like i got his date and
so he says well with who and when she told him
he's like golly he's like the ugliest guy in
the village but you know what his sister said
yeah but he's the smartest right you know we don't
you know smart people in our country get you know
you know they you know it's the captain of the
football team the guy who can rap the best the guy
who can dunk the ball all right those are the ones
who put on pedestals often the people who are very
really smart have to hide it uh and you know
that's a detriment it's it's always been a
detriment but even more so as we go into this
new economy uh which is more intellectually
based and you know based on physical brawn yeah
it is an interesting idea and you know i think
speaking of moving into this new economy where
it is very tech driven and you know we always
talk about this um on your show people often say
that we live in the most privileged era where we
have access to unlimited information where you can
build an empire from your mom's basement if you've
got some good wi-fi you know you can really do
anything from anywhere you can access a global
market so would you agree firstly that we do live
in one of the most privileged times absolutely
absolutely uh you know there's just no
there's just no doubt about it you know
just like you said the reach the ability
to you know to start a business you know
put out some ads on facebook or whatever it's
it's that you know but it also is competitive
right i mean the ease of ease of entry means
there's a billion other people doing it right so
you know whereas if it was harder you would
have maybe fewer competitors but penetrating
the market and creating a business uh that part
is really great and when i started my business
because you know i have my own business aside
from fox yeah yeah so when i started my business
i started again out of a one bedroom apartment
in harlem it's a research business and what
i would do is i i would write the research at
night and then i was a salesman in the daytime
and there was this big book it was really thick
it had to be like at least a foot i mean they
used to call it the red book it had a red cover
it was a directory of all the brokers in america
and i would just go through the red
book calling people up cold calling
you know hey you should try my research to
try my research you know how hard that is
you know and so it's a grind uh you know but
it is what it is right yeah i mean i just i
just wonder then you know given i also think
we live in one of the most privileged times um
so i'm trying to understand you know why there
is this sort of growing unrest in america
and also globally um in terms of this whole
diversity narrative um this idea that you know
we live in the most oppressed times women are the
most depressed well as a woman i totally disagree
i think we're the most liberated right now and i
think that's sort of bad in some ways but that's
another it's another that's another topic um
but you know surely technology has leveled
that playing field so why if we can agree it's
the most privileged times why are we apparently
more oppressed than ever you know i think that's
more of a political narrative than anything else
you know there's a lot of power out there to make
people feel oppressed to make people hate each
other to make people feel animosity uh and and
the power centers of our country of our countries
and around the world really the west in particular
but certainly in the united states is centered on
grievance and and you know when you start to take
that away then these organizations can't exist
the day after the day after
barack obama was elected
i got an email from the nc uh uh national
association for advancement of colored people
um that was ominous that you know now that obama's
elected it's going to be worse for black people so
because you know there's there's a backlash
even to this day you hear people you know talk
you hear people say oh you know now
the races are going to really come out
you know so there's a backlash you know uh it's
it's it's nonsensical in a sense that uh you know
this is the same country that elected a black man
but then they hate him at the same time it just
doesn't make sense if you step back even for
a nanosecond and pay attention but that's the
narrative because they can't give up what are they
going to do say we don't want to be in business
anymore they're going to fold up their tent you
know people are going to give up those six-figure
jobs and their privilege and their speeches and
they're going to give all that up and do what you
know and and you know it's the same thing whether
it's unions whether it's that whether it's this no
one's going to give up that power uh and so it's
the the oppression meal ticket is a multi-billion
maybe fifty hundred billion dollar thing and the
power that comes with it is amazing as well so
and you know same thing with political power you
know and that's that's why i hate politicians who
who spend too much time telling me about someone
that hates me or that spends too much time telling
me what the other person's doing i always want
to hear what they're going to do um you know and
you know it's it's it's gotten very despicable and
i think it's going to get more despicable because
you have these older politicians who have no
clue that you know people younger people your
age and even younger are closer than
anyone else you know like you know it
has ever been you know again if you go back to
my old block there were no white people zero zero
and you know you couldn't meet any
unless you maybe had a few at school
you couldn't there was no internet to meet any you
couldn't share the music you know there was not
no way to interact with any white person of
course now that's all people do is interact
with different people all around the world
you know so i think it's a beautiful thing
um but there's some really powerful
nefarious forces that hate to see it happen
yeah i think it's really sad because i also agree
i think it's a beautiful thing um you know i'm not
one of those um people that scream diversity i'm
just happy to live in a meritocracy um you know
equality of opportunity rather than outcome um
but it's so funny because you know people always
scream oh you're sexist racist this all that if
you just sort of want to see a meritocracy um
that is no i i guess because there's there's
it's rare that there truly is a true meritocracy
there's always something that kind of tilts
something in someone's favor a little bit
which is this real talk you know it's it's like
you know you go and you start the job same time
as someone else maybe they went to school with the
boss or the boss's daughter or the same alma mater
they live in the same town they like the
same movie there's always kind of something
that you know it's hard to find in this world
of isms and it's not just racism or sexism or
you know there's all kinds
of elitism and this isn't so
you know i i don't ever tell anybody that that
i don't know too many areas where there's truly
uh true meritocracy but i do know the harder
you work the harder it's going to be hard for
someone to stop you you know what i mean like if
you bust your ass and you learn and you overcome
you become a battering ram i don't give a damn
the more you become a battering ram the harder
it is for someone to stop you so you know
and the reason i say that because i don't
want people to get disillusioned like well i did
everything else they did well then whatever else
you got to do do it right because because if
you want that you've got to go get it and and
no one's going to give it to you they'll give
you crumbs they'll give you crumbs all day long
you know uh higher minimum wage yeah step right
up vote for me i'll give you a higher minimum wage
you want to live in a project public housing
i'm your man you know oh i'll raise you above
the poverty line so what does that really mean
well in america that means we'll take a family of
four from 26 000 a year to 27 000 a year you know
so you know so i i i do i believe in meritocracy
as well but i just think it's it's i've never
been in a position anywhere in my life where
just truly the best and the hardest working
uh is an automatic path you know sometimes it
takes a little bit more than that and it's fine
because you know what you have sharp elbows look
at you you're a dynamo right so no one if you if
you sense some [ __ ] you're gonna you're gonna
sharpen your elbows and you're gonna still power
right through it yeah i mean i just yeah i still
just try my best um because i want certain things
i want so you know like my my whole mentality is
like i don't wanna rely on anyone or anything
um you know and it's not a feminist mentality at
all because i'm really not into that um i just i
just think we all have to be careful in this world
because you never know what tomorrow brings you
know even if it's just like bad health you know
sure oh you're going to be able to pay those bills
if it's a family member that's sick you want to be
able to pay those bills like i just don't want to
struggle you know um and and even on just like a
superficial level like if i'm not being funny but
if i want to get another perfume i don't want to
ask someone for that i want to be able to go and
afford a chanel perfume myself like i know that
sounds superficial but it's just i don't want
to ask i want to be able to do you know and and
then also just giving back as well which is really
which is which is which is the next level of like
achievement um when you can give back and and i
feel like that's something you're doing actually
um like i really love what's going on right now
with fox business i love that you're bringing in i
wasn't gonna ask you about this but i'm just gonna
do it anyway i love that you're bringing in loads
of people from crypto twitter um you know young
people like myself people younger than me um i
think it's incredible i'm not i'm not seeing this
anywhere else actually a little bit in the uk but
that's more for diversity reasons in my opinion
um but tell me about this how come you're you know
you're really talking about crypto and bringing in
young people it's not even just crypto i just want
young people i you know why first and foremost
like you i believe in economic freedom right
personal freedom is just it's just let me tell
you something sometimes i walk out my bedroom door
and i look down on my house and the feeling is
just like oh my goodness i can't even describe it
like you know it's like look at this amazing house
right it's like look at this it's a [ __ ] mansion
right and yeah and i earned this [ __ ] from
nothing i had nothing i don't know how i got
there i really couldn't tell you exactly and and i
want this for people particularly young people and
you know i got to be honest you're very observant
because no one is doing what i'm doing in terms of
like how how much time i spend looking for new
guests all the time and you know i'm looking
at i like i like to find people who who write or
who seem to you know who know what they're talking
about i you know i like to read the reporting
or whatever uh you know and and i just think
that if we empower younger generations then then
that's how we keep this thing going right because
it's not we're not ordained and none of us are you
know like i know listen i think america right for
what is achieved in such a short period of time
considering how old civilization is is absolutely
remarkable you know the super you know the pass up
the great great britain in the 1900s early 1900s
um but i also believe that a lot of people have
gotten to the point where they think it's ordained
you know just kind of wake up yeah god blessed
america yeah well you got to get up and earn
it though yeah you just got to sit back and
you know because you know once because once
you lose it i don't think you get it back so
so you know i and i just and by the way i'm
i love what i'm seeing with young investors and
it's just and it's crypto but it's also stocks
and and i just i i love it because it was it
was my salvation you know i when i was 14 i went
and i told my mom i said i'm gonna work on wall
street that's amazing and let me tell you nobody
but my mom believed me nobody i called my dad
on the phone i said daddy i'm gonna work on
wall street you say man i saw it on tv one
bunch of white guys throwing paper in here
i see no he said i see no black
people down there like thanks dad
i'm gone that's so amazing i just i love that so
much i think that's that's what it's all about
for me um you know that's why i'm interested in
bitcoin um because i feel like it really levels
the playing field um and it brings back that fresh
opportunity you know and i know millennials often
feel like the um the opportunity is gone you
know it's hard to get on the property ladder
the infrastructure is built now america's built
everything's built um but now we're building new
things um and so it's finally an opportunity um to
start again so this leads me to my my next point
so i thought you're an example of the american
dream um and i love it um so to what extent would
you say the american dream is dead you know given
inflation biden and all that fun stuff um you know
the wars the centralization of power and all this
stuff versus a new era that was sort of going into
i don't i don't think it's dead you know i just
think people have to to work for it right and
you know it's you think of some of the other
generations and the greatest generation in
world war ii world war one world war ii uh even
people who young people who fought in vietnam
you know my dad fought in vietnam and to be honest
with you when he came back he was never the same
and sadly um he only told me a little bit
about that just a few months before he died
why he changed and twice he had gone out with
his crew whatever you know and twice he was
the only one who survived and so he was mad
at god he was mad at everyone you know that
and it was hard for him to love to be vulnerable
so there are generations that all face obstacles
um so i think the american dream is alive and
well it's got to be you got a 22 trillion dollar
economy are you kidding me but you got to you got
to get in there right and again it's easier to set
it up but that means there are more people maybe
doing it that means you gotta be smarter more
innovative you still gotta have that hustle that
grind um you know and and i just think too many
people have grown up without it and they don't
know how to get it uh and you know and and so
ultimately you know getting becoming very
successful is not luck right you know
every now and then maybe someone may stumble on
something but for the most part it is a dedication
a grind overcoming obstacles getting smacked down
a few times climbing back off the canvas that kind
of thing so the american dream is alive and well
and like you though i think what's happening you
know blockchain crypto you know the metaverse um
you know just this whole new world uh you know
listen i i'm a i you know the story ned lud no so
so when they first had the weaving machines uh you
know he was really upset his name like king led
net love they called him king lud anyway he led a
revolt one night because people were losing their
jobs right you know it took like all these women
and men who were making these you know things
he they started bringing these big machines i
was doing the work of like 10 people so one night
him and a bunch of people broke into like a little
factory and they broke them up so anyone who's
afraid of advancement now is known as a luddite
right or technology so i'm something of a luddite
not that i'm afraid of it but you know i'm not the
best at it you know i actually get on the phone on
the elevator like it took me so damn long to get
a smartphone but i was also embarrassed so when i
would get on the elevator my like old school phone
i would be acting like i was sending an email even
though because everybody else was in an email me
too but um so i i'm sort of a luddite right but
i think we're in a fourth industrial revolution
yeah and so you know robots flying taxis and all
of these things are just so absolutely amazing
the sad thing though is if you don't prepare
for it the right way you're going to be left
behind and so we're going to have a we're going
to have another group of haves and have-nots and
this won't be based on race as and and all the
other things is to be based more on intellect
and and you know people who have actually prepared
for it invested in it or learned about it and
then it would be the rest yeah i think you're
absolutely spot on i totally agree with you
that's why i'm investing like i'm crazy right now
i'm just trying to like every day i'm like yeah
i'm in on that new [ __ ] coin i'm in on that
new meme coin i don't care just just put it in
um yeah i'm going crazy with it um but i'd love to
understand how you first heard about bitcoin and
crypto and you know what was your initial thoughts
when you first heard about it um i heard about it
a long time ago i read about it somewhere a long
time ago and i thought it was very very intriguing
but my my biggest obstacle was this
notion that some kind of super formula
was created some sort of software
and it'd only be x amount of um
uh hold on i'm sorry no worries hello
okay yeah so um there would be
x amount you know i just thought
i loved listen i'm not a fan
of fiat currency i do think
uh you know that that i i do believe one day this
whole thing will implode i don't know what this
the final thing will be that makes it implode
it might be something small right like all these
major structures that eventually collapse it's
not as you know if you get so deteriorated beneath
the surface that it won't take much but i don't
know what the magic number is or what it is but
they've just ruined it so badly um so i just never
trusted the idea that this formula was foolproof
so i used to have an office also on the 17th
floor here and john stossel uh who's a real famous
newsman in america um he was into it
early and it's uh one of his assistants
she was into it early she's always come by the
office and this is like it was like three thousand
right you surprised some of that bitcoin i'm
like yeah yeah yeah okay yeah i hear you you know
so i was always into interested in that
they want to collapse the first time
i kind of like say yeah okay that's what i thought
but when it made the rebound that's when it got
started getting my attention then i learned more
about the blockchain than about you know the you
know the the sort of decentralized financing and
um you know i just became more and more intrigued
yeah i want to pick you up on your point
about the dollar um do you think the dollar
is at risk of losing its place in the world
um as you know that world reserve currency
um you know i imagine for example inflation is
so much more than 7.9 um so what's gonna you
know i know you don't know exactly how but like
people are losing trust in the us dollar yeah
will it lose it's you know will it lose it it's
gone i think it would have already if there was
an alternative right the only thing that you can
say is that everybody has to base their currency
right you know you look at the european central
bank the bank of england the bank of japan
i mean some of the things they've done is
like ah lee they're buying stocks right
so they've all gone off the reservation right um
uh but i do believe it's interesting because today
one of my topics is as saudi arabia buying oil in
the yuan rather than a dollar those are your first
signs you know one of the main things that keeps
the dollar the world's reserve currency is that
people pay for oil with dollars which is why
this whole push by progressives in america to
get rid of oil they are so damn stupid for so
many reasons it's like you guys don't realize
you're gonna you're just gonna make it easier
to get off the us dollar and that full faith
and credit that gets you a lot of stuff you know
that gets all this money coming into here into
this country is gonna go away it's going to go
to taiwan it's going to go to vietnam it's going
to go to china it's going to go to africa all that
money that we get in part because of a rule of law
all right and and and you know and just all the
things that make you the world's reserve currency
one of the big parts of it is crude oil so
i just find it so amazing they want to get
rid of it they have no clue no clue unless
they really do want you know maybe they want
some form of armageddon because that's
what they're going get uh and and and so
it will at one point at some point it will
lose that uh for a few years ago maybe a
decade ago there was a talk of a basket of
currencies sort of like what the imf has
imf has these five five currencies in a basket
and that's sort of what they call a special
drawing rights uh and so there's been there
was talk of maybe a special drawing rights
uh superseding the dollar so it would be the yuan
uh the euro the dollar uh and uh the pound and i
forgot what the other thing was maybe the swiss
franc so mm-hmm or no the swiss doesn't frank
anymore whatever it was something else but so
it will lose it at some point it's inevitable
yeah and you said it's you know there's no
alternative but i mean do you see bitcoin
at this stage as being an alternative obviously
not right now but you know el salvador's adopting
bitcoin as legal tender um you know i'm starting
to see some states in the u.s um talking about
allowing people to pay their taxes and bitcoin
which for those watching don't do that i think
that's a terrible idea for many reasons um so you
know you're always asking me on the show but what
about you like where do you see bitcoin's role in
the world i i think it's got to evolve you know
here's the thing i think we got bitcoin uh you got
two things it's got to overcome a few tests right
you know to prove itself um you know you know
these transitions just don't happen overnight
i think you taught me that and um and it's got
opposition you know we talked i was talking
earlier to you about these powerful entities that
want to keep their power no matter what and a lot
of their power is based on you know grievance and
and animosity of people toward other people but
the ultimate power of these world governments
i mean imagine them giving up fiat currency
golly like you know the notion that they
couldn't print themselves out of a jam anymore
whoa are you serious it's like you know
i mean it's it's it's it's unthinkable
it's unthinkable think about how much money has
been printed in the last four years than the last
10 years just out of thin air between all these
central banks imagine giving that up so now you
really have to solve problems through serious belt
tightening through years of recessions you know
uh or or they would call them um uh with
golly what was the name of them before
you know they got rid of the name and and in
the 1880s there were like four of these big
giant great recession type periods oh man i don't
know if it's the 80s maybe no no in the 1880s
yeah depression nothing not depression golly
they had a different name for it anyway
they actually changed the name because it was
so rough and that's when they came up this this
is you know the federal reserve in the early
1900s and they were supposed to stop this boom
bust cycle and they said if we ever have it again
we're not going to call it that they said let's
just call it a depression so anyway they would
be these you know they had to ever have to gut
it out if these countries ever had to gut it
out you would talk about 12 years of recession
you know there would be 20 years of depression
and they they don't want to go through that so
they're to fight tooth and nail to make sure
bitcoin never achieves its ultimate potential
doesn't mean they're going to be successful
but they are going to fight tooth and now
to make sure it never happens yeah
i'm so ready for it i'm so ready
i've got some lip gloss i've got
a very sharp lip liner charles
hey you can put a wick in that lip gloss
lighting and throw it maybe you know okay
there you go nobody you know the reason i say i'm
ready for it is because um the last two years for
me have just been so inhumane um you know you
know forcing medical procedures and so on and so
on so i think people are not just losing trust in
the us dollar but they like you mentioned earlier
they're losing trust in the establishment as a
whole whether it's news media unfortunately you
know i think cnn were very confused as to
why people preferred joe rogan over cnn um
that wasn't that much of a shocker um you know
and also um you know the the medical industry
now unfortunately people are losing losing faith
in so in your opinion you know where do we go from
here like how do we how do we heal as a society
because we're becoming more divided um you know
it was black versus white then it was vaccinated
versus unvaccinated now it's like russia versus
ukraine and you know if you don't say anything
then you're pro-putin um you know it's it's just
crazy it's like we we just have to we argue over
everything and we just don't need to you know
um i i think the uh you know you kind of you kind
of answered it a little bit when you brought up
brogan versus cnn so you're talking about right
you're talking about uh one entity that used to
you know that doesn't even get a million viewers
versus one who gets 11 million um you know i think
and i think it happens when we start to bypass all
of these folks who tell us how to think and they
tell us how to think not not out of altruistic
reasons but to again to preserve their power
all right so msnbc all day long oh my god just
i didn't do they ever get tired of blaming trump
for everything could they ever get tired of
promoting hate do they ever get tired of it
you know um might not come as a shock to you but i
watched very little uh cable news or any news that
it doesn't come as a shocking tool very little
very little um you know when i'm not when i'm not
working i love movies and um old tv shows i've
been watching the original year of hawaii five
of you ever want to find a great series i've
been watching the first season of that that's
some amazing tv anyway i digressed a little bit
nah it's good but i think i think it'll happen
you know as as we find a way to communicate and
bypass the gatekeepers and the opinion makers
and once we start to do that because people
will find hey you know what i get a lot in
common with this other person and and again i'm
seeing it already you know uh you know i see it
with my son who by the way went to university in
london oh nice yeah yeah and he just had an art
show this week and his best friend from london
came over they're coming to the studio today
oh amazing yeah so and then of course you know you
know i looked at him and his friends you know his
first girlfriend was from sweden his best friend
another best friend was from the middle east
another one was from africa and you go over there
and you hang with them and you just kind of sit
back and like you know they just love each other
you know because of who they are and no one can
make them not love each other and so as we get rid
of those power structures that just live off that
that crap um i think we'll have a reawakening
in what we can do and achieve on our own
and that's why i'm really if you ever see me on
tv going off and politics is always on stuff like
know like higher minimum wage stuff like that that
you know just anything that keeps you dependent
uh on on government anything that stops you
from being able to nurture your god-given gifts
because i believe everybody has god-given gifts
but i think you know often you have to nurture
them you have to see them find them nurture them
and if you don't nurture them if you if you do a
foul-stand deal and you keep them suppressed and
in return you take free a higher minimum wage and
free this and free that you've actually destroyed
your life you've destroyed the gifts that you've
never even led blossom in exchange for crumbs
yeah i i totally agree with you i
think that's such an eloquent way
of putting it i also hate minimum wage it's
so counterproductive um it literally screws
the very people they're trying to help and
i often wonder whether it's destruction by
design right like whether they do this on purpose
um to keep you dependent that's sort of the way
the democrats look i don't know what do you
think design op essence um you remember that
term uh there's a term i think it's design ops
ah oppolepsince uh golly now i'm mumbling here
when things are designed to go become obsolete
oh oh oh like they say about like apple and tech
um um obsolete is my dad uses it what is it
yeah it's it started back in i think yeah 60s
early 60s or late 50s um designed obsolescence
yeah yeah i think yeah yeah i think that's it so
i think um i think this guy i want to say he was
um anyway one of the auto executives uh talked
about it and you know the cars were designed to
work a certain amount of time and then break yes
right so you have to buy another one and the
same thing to your point with society you know
it's designed a certain way because if you ever
have to supersede the need to take their crumbs
they're nothing they have nothing over you yeah
you lose their job you don't have to vote for them
yeah no i i i totally agree with you um i'd like
to get your thoughts as well um on the current
crypto regulation biden's executive order um
i feel like the roles are turning right now
this is what you would ask me but what are your
thoughts charles on on biden's executive order
uh you know what i was shocked at how many
of my crypto guests thought it was good news
i guess i guess it's um that's why you're
my favorite crypto guest uh thank you
i guess it's good in a sense that it's
orderly yes right you know i mean you got
you know it's not the wild wild west
where everyone comes in like you know you
imagine a town with 25 different sheriffs right
and they all have their own rules like oh man
hey what are you told you can drink out of
there uh the sheriff so-and-so well you can't
okay so maybe yeah you know maybe we'll
get all of it down into one you know into
one package and one set of rules but
what the hell are those rules going to be
so also if you saw the testimony of jay powell
you know these are called the humphrey hawkins
he goes up to congress and he speaks to congress
to the house and then the senate oh my goodness
i mean he was he was really talking about you know
this need for this central bank digital currency
elizabeth warren used all her time to rail against
the nefarious evilness of bitcoin uh you know and
yeah and that's something that's bipartisan
you have people on both sides of the aisle
so yeah you know what let's go where we've got
to go i know in early may all of all the comments
have to be in on the central bank cryptocurrency
uh then after that they'll look at them and then i
i would suspect in about a month after that we'll
get the next move from the fed uh but i'm just a
little i'm just a little anxious that's all i'm
just a little anxious and i've already told you
i just can't see them allowing this to blossom to
its full potential without trying to sabotage it
yeah i think we're in um that fight stage
um which is just a phase um i think we will
pass it anything new always goes through always
goes through those stages i love your optimism
oh thank you no it's true i think so i i really
think so i think it's just you know i look at
it also quite like philosophical like good will
prevail and i think bitcoin is good i think it's
humanitarian money um and you know um we're just
going through a cycle right now right now we're
hitting peak centralization but i don't think
that will last um a guest on one of my shows said
there's going to be a blow off top um in terms of
um you know decentralization just blowing through
because because it's become too much um and yeah i
think it's gonna be really interesting i'm kind of
grateful actually that i'm living at during a time
where we can witness all of this right right yeah
um but just finally um two more questions
for you some if somebody had to do 50 000
clear and free today um and you
have a choice to either buy bitcoin
or buy gold and you have to hold it for 10 years
which are you buying charles i would buy bitcoin
why i think it's got more upside potential uh
you know i i you know you know i've i've got
boats i probably haven't uh i got more money into
gold only because i was buying it a long time ago
yeah that makes sense uh and every now and then
and i like by the way i like the gold bars right
i mean i have two nothing but you
know the big ones the things like
you know yeah the only thing is i don't know where
they are like my wife took them put them somewhere
and i keep saying like you know where's my goal
no i got it i i'm like can i get my gold please
anyway um you need better self-custody charles
come on oh yeah yeah so i would you know i i
think gold will have a position but i think like
you i think bitcoin has so much upside potential
so definitely i would buy bitcoin over gold
if i had to buy one or the other right now
that's a good one um and then just finally
um given everything that we've spoken about
um and it's been a great conversation um what
would be your number one advice uh your top you
know the top sort of line that you would say to
people wanting to make it in this world um sort
of feeling like you know everything sort of
against them right now and you know looking
to rise above their circumstances what would be
the number one piece of advice you'd give them
i i uh
you have to make it you really have
to make it happen um it's not there's
it's not going to come out of fairness of the
system uh there are going to be people that you
meet who are going to be incredibly kind and
generous you don't know where they're going
to be you know who they're going to be uh you
know and and i've been so fortunate that every
now and then while there was a teacher you
know here or a person there but just every
now and then someone just kind of nudged me
a little bit so that's going to happen people
should know that's going to happen but none
all of this happens when you stay in the fight
when you stay in the fight and you're committed to
being a better version of you you're gonna succeed
and again you can go down you can go sideways
but if you still go home that night and do your
work and do your research and you put in
the extra time if you're a better version
of yourself every single day you're going to
make it charles i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure speaking with you i
love your your intellect i like your passion
your hustle your drive your love of personal
responsibility and you know your respect i
think we need more of that in this world um i
think absolutely brilliant so thank you so much
for coming on thank you so much yeah you're
you're fantastic too i'm glad to know you
the leia fan show sponsored by step
finance your go-to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start